je vais t'en prendre extrêmement soin
mais kim kardashian a abîmé la robe
mythique de marilyn monroe lors du
dernier gala du met c'est ce qu'affirme
photos avant/après à l'appui le compte
instagram marilyn monroe collectionne
propriétaire du vêtement sur les clichés
il manque plusieurs des six mille
cristaux cousu main c'est le tissu est
déchirée par endroits ce qui me
kardashian avait perdu sept kilos pour
rentrer dans cette robe iconique que
personne n'avait porté depuis 1962 et le
célèbre happy birthday au président
kennedy
[Musique]
il faut ici focal en bourse ah bah oui
mais jamais été porté depuis ce jour la
légende dit qu'elle était cousue sur le
corps demain il exact auquel assez
complète le couturier il l'a terminée
sur est donc été vraiment plaisir sur ne
sait plus sur mesure c'était une seconde
peau mais pourquoi on a autorisé alors
parce que c'est kim kardashian
[Musique]
temps des deux petites secondes on
concède le tourneur jean louis il est
d'origine française il va vraiment
réalisé la robe à même le corps de
marina saisir le nom des backstage il va
vraiment venir contre c'est de la soie
et c'est du cristal c'est extrêmement
fins c'est une robe qui leur est devenue
iconique vous le dit contrat de 4,5
millions d'euros c'est quelque chose qui
note de dollars quelque chose qui n'a
jamais été atteint là une autre robe qui
pourrait rentrer dans ce palmarès à
l'étang france et la fameuse rock audrey
hepburn a apporté dans diamants sur
canapé qui a été racheté par bernard
arnault pour un million de dollars oui
vous voyez que la différence est quand
même encore énorme y en eut deux
dortoirs mais 62 et el mar au mois
d'août elles marquent quelques mois plus
tard donc la légende aussi fait partie
de cela puisqu'on sait très bien que le
président qui est déjà son amant mort
lui aussi quelques semaines après c'est
la robe qui fait partie de la légende
marilyn kennedy elle ne devait pas être
portées c'est une robe qui doit rester
dans un musée je suis d'accord avec toi
alors pourquoi il ya un côté bertrand
pacé kim kardashian
du coup et d'attendre une garde un sens
pas non plus voilà ce que je
disais j'ai fait qu'elle aurait en effet
été un peu voilà qu'elle n'aurait pas
perdu suffisamment de quoi on parle
aussi du fait qualité extrêmement
maquiller qu'elle porte à lait corporel
aussi qui était très présent et qui
sauverait taxi le salami à l'ami du lait
graal à
dire davantage n'a aucune classe